hey guys it is February the 11th my name
is Jess McDowell and you're watching the
show that's commonly referred to as
gamespot knees please see a doctor here
experienced any adverse side effects if
you're a person who's been holding out
on buying Aveda then you might be
interested to hear that the Vedas loin
is coming to the u.s. this brings the
15% lighter and 20% slimmer version is
also called the PlayStation Vita 2000
which really just makes me think of
olsommer 3000 so let's go with blimp now
apart from the size difference the
battery life is a tad longer but
unfortunately the screen on this model
is LCD instead of the original brighter
OLEDs the Wi-Fi only version will also
be shipping in a Borderlands 2 bundle
where you can grab the system the game
and an 8 gigabyte memory card for 200
bucks
the console had its European launch last
week are you tempted or has the Vita yet
to pique your interest next up you can
use your own chat headset with the Xbox
one but it looks like you'll have to pay
25 bucks to do so basically that 25
bucks is going toward a tiny piece of
plastic with five buttons on it which
will serve as your adapter to any and
all non default headset obviously
Microsoft would probably prefer you to
check out their own headset which comes
with its own detachable adapter and is
all set to retail 480 American dollars
generally you guys seem pretty pleased
by the news in the comments on sites but
my favorite of today has to go to the
FAA 1509 who is nice Sony's marketing
team must be pissed that Microsoft is
selling more PS boards than they are
it's a joke again please don't hurt me
are you guys on the side of the
aggravated on this one or do you think
it's okay let me know NPS for news the
console is getting over 100 games this
year so hopefully finally doesn't
something to play on the thing so many
tweeted out the news
140 characters is the new press release
and confirmed this software scene is
ready to go for 2014 before you ask I
have no idea how many games are
currently in the works for the Xbox one
speaking of what exactly is in the work
though you guys seem a little hesitant
over just how many of these 100 games
are going to be quality and how many are
just bulking up quantities by the way I
generally see more games as a good thing
but let me know what games you want to
see from the new consoles yeah either in
the comments down below or you can do so
on my Twitter where I'm at just install
that's it for me but do check out our
site for more videos news and all that
good stuff today may I recommend you
weigh in on bad video game title on the
gym